[Music]  [Music]  yeah be  [Music]  I've been making costumes my entire life  22 years ago I started to make what I  call extreme costumes those are costumes  that'll Wow thousands of people at a  time and I'm pretty happy doing that  [Music]  you've got all kinds of fun little  gimmicks in it the jaw moves the eyes  light up horns and move around you got  all kinds of stuff each individual hand  has a minimum of 16 controls in it  everyone said to me it's too complicated  you won't be able to do it I guess we're  gonna find out  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  it's my sixth one that's right six plus  one more  you know Bond movies he's a protector  he's my favorite Autobot I'm a giant  Transformers fan I want to get him  purpose  [Music]  [Music]  you go out you enjoy your life but  everyone just treats you like normal but  here I get to be a superstar for just a  few days and I love that feeling it's a  great feeling  [Music]